Transcription: Niki Sofou
Relecteur: Eleni Tziafa
L’information que je m’apprête
à vous donner va, je l’espère,
créer chez nous tous un réel électrochoc.
D’après une étude publiée en 2017
dans la revue Science,
dès l’âge de 6 ans,
les filles se croient
moins intelligentes que les garçons.
Je m’appelle Bérengère Soyer,
j’ai 31 ans et je suis chef d’entreprise.
Je suis aussi femme, mère,
épouse, sœur, amie,
mais surtout, je suis militante
pour l’émancipation économique
des femmes et des filles dans le monde.
« C’est une petite capricieuse
à qui on ne peut rien dire.
Elle est sauvage de toute façon. »
C’est ainsi que mes grands parents
paternels qualifiaient mon envie
déjà d'indépendance.
J’avais 6 ou 7 ans et dès lors,
mon caractère rebelle ne plaisait pas,
Caractère de cochon, sale caractère,
autoritaire sont les qualificatifs
qui m’ont accompagné durant mon enfance
et durant mon apprentissage de la vie.
Je ne suis pas une fille des quartiers,
je ne suis pas née dans la pauvreté,
je n’ai pas une histoire tragique, non.
Mais j'ai grandi dans une famille,
dans un cadre patriarcal.
Les hommes dans mon entourage étaient
soit militaires, soit médecins.
Les femmes, femmes d’eux,
femmes au foyer ou enseignantes.
Le schéma manichéen m'a formaté
dès ma plus tendre enfance.
J’ai vite été une fille libre
et surtout très affranchie
des règles familiales
imposées par une
étiquette surannée.
À mes dépens, j’ai vite réalisé
que cette culture familiale se répétait
de génération en génération,
sans que quiconque vienne
la remettre en question.
Alors, avec mon caractère rebelle
et mon caractère de cochon,
j’ai décidé d’inverser
l’angle de vue de la situation
et de tester ce que ma mère adore appeler
un métier d’homme : l’entrepreneuriat.
Au quotidien, dans les images
que nous diffusons, dans nos propos,
dans les modèles que nous construisons
et que nous regardons,
nous diffusons des clichés,
des stéréotypes.
Ces idées reçues persistent
et encore en 2021,
le potentiel des femmes est
le potentiel économique
le moins exploité au monde.
Pour permettre un monde réellement
égalitaire, il nous faut à tout prix,
et dès à présent déconstruire
nos croyances fondées
sur notre Histoire avec un grand H
et ancrées dans la culture populaire,
reconstruire des codes inclusifs
qui parlent aux femmes et aux filles
et enfin permettre aux femmes
de s’autonomiser
financièrement et économiquement
pour créer de nouvelles richesses
dans le futur et dans le monde.
Depuis quatre ans, j’étudie les femmes
et leur capacité à prendre leur place
dans un monde principalement dominé
par la gente masculine.
Comme j’aime à le répéter,
les hommes d’aujourd’hui n’ont pas
à se sentir coupables de cette situation.
Leurs prédécesseurs
ont construit des normes,
un langage utilisé
par des hommes pour des hommes
à une époque où la femme était
complètement absente
de la sphère économique.
En 1965 pour la première fois,
les femmes ont le droit d’ouvrir
un compte bancaire sans l’autorisation
de leur père ou de leur mari.
55 ans à l’échelle de notre humanité.
Qu’est ce que cela représente ?
Faites le test et regardez autour de vous.
Quels sont les modèles féminins
qui vous viennent en tête
lorsque vous pensez
chef d’entreprise ayant réussi,
scientifique ayant fait
une découverte majeure,
Journalistes, économistes,
personnalités médiatiques, etc.
Excepté les extraordinaires,
Michelle Obama, Oprah Winfrey,
Marie Curie, Simon Veil,
la liste est relativement courte.
Les modèles féminins ne sont pas visibles.
Nous ne pouvons donc pas
nous construire en nous identifiant.
Pire, les filles d’aujourd’hui
s’autocensurent
tellement les clichés ont la vie dure.
Voici la figure complexe de Ray.
Des chercheurs de l’Université de Provence
ont fait passer un test
à des écoliers et des écolières.
Ces derniers allaient devoir reproduire
à main levée et de tête
cette figure relativement complexe.
À un premier groupe, on indique
qu’il s’agit d’un exercice de géométrie
et à un deuxième groupe,
qu’il s’agit d’un test de dessin.
Résultat, lorsque l’on dit
qu’il s’agit d’un test de géométrie,
les filles obtiennent de moins bons
résultats que les garçons
et lorsque l’on indique
qu’il s’agit d’ un test de dessin,
les filles obtiennent
de meilleurs résultats.
Le test est pourtant
rigoureusement le même.
Ainsi, la seule évocation de la géométrie,
et donc des mathématiques
constitue un réel obstacle pour les filles
qui, très tôt, intègrent l’idée
qu’elles sont moins bonnes
en mathématiques que les garçons.
Malheureusement,
les filles n’intègrent pas
naturellement les filières
scientifiques, technologiques
ou les écoles d’ingénieurs, par exemple.
Non seulement les femmes
et les filles sont conditionnées
par notre Ηistoire avec un grand H
et par cette culture populaire,
mais elles sont aussi conditionnées
par des expressions bien ancrées
telles que autoritaires,
sauvages, capricieuses,
que l’on recrée aisément
par indépendant, ambitieux,
pour des petits garçons.
Au détour de l’expression
d’un mécontentement
un peu plus fort que d’habitude,
qui n’a jamais entendu
l’expression hystérique ?
Maladie décrite par Hippocrate
dans l’Antiquité
comme intimement liée à l’utérus,
du latin hysteria, qui signifie matrice
une maladie, donc, exclusivement féminine
qui n’a jamais, au détour
d’une conversation sous couvert d’humour,
traiter une sœur, une mère,
une amie d’hystérique ?
Au 16e siècle, ces troubles hystériques
justifiaient l’exclusion des femmes,
des sphères du pouvoir et du savoir.
J’ai eu l’occasion
durant ces quatre dernières années
de rencontrer des centaines de femmes
et d’essayer de comprendre
leurs problématiques
et surtout comment elles avaient bataillé
au quotidien pour faire leur place
dans un monde principalement dominé
par la gente masculine.
Ces catégories de femmes
se scindent en deux :
soit elles se sont épuisées
à essayer de survivre
en développant leurs activités,
par exemple d’indépendante,
soit elles ont décidé
d’adopter les codes masculins
au détriment de leur nature profonde
et sous couvert d’être taxée
d’’ambitieuses ou d’égoïstes.
Parce que oui,
dans notre imaginaire collectif,
ambitions et femmes
ne font pas encore bon ménage.
Pour aller un peu plus loin
dans les problématiques
spécifiques aux femmes,
et quand je vous aurais partagé
quelques pépites,
vous comprendrez pourquoi je dis
spécifiques aux femmes.
Je voulais vous partager quelques
témoignages de ces femmes
qui au quotidien, se battent pour exister
dans le paysage économique.
Virginie, à Guipry :
« Lorsque je me suis rendu à la banque
pour demander un prêt
nécessaire au lancement de mon activité,
le banquier n’a accepté
qu’à une seule condition :
que je sois placée
sous la tutelle de mon mari. »
Sophie à Agent :
« On me demandait constamment
de revenir avec un dossier plus complet.
Au bout d’un moment,
je me suis mise à douter
et à me demander si j’étais légitime. »
Enfin, Nathalie, à Lille :
« L’ idée de demander
de l’argent me freinait
car je me demandais si c’était
réellement ma place. »
Tous ces témoignages datent de 2019
et montrent à quel point les femmes ont
un rapport tronqué à l’argent
et à la confiance en elles.
Tout comme j’ai été amené
à le faire plus jeune
ce n’est plus aux femmes
de s’adapter à la société,
mais bien à notre Société avec un grand S,
les femmes et les hommes
d’inverser notre angle de vue.
et de s’adapter à la condition intrinsèque
des femmes qui font maintenant
aussi partie des sphères
du pouvoir et du savoir.
Et tant que l’homo sapiens femme,
sera l’unique être habilité à porter,
à mettre au monde
et à nourrir le nouveau né,
il faudra des conditions de travail
qui s’adaptent à la grossesse,
mais aussi à l’allaitement,
des conditions de salaire
qui prennent en compte le temps de congé
maternité post et pré accouchement,
mais aussi, de fait, le temps mis entre
parenthèses durant toute une carrière.
Ce n’est plus à la femme de s’adapter
à la société et aux codes désuets
mais bien la société de s’adapter.
Aujourd’hui encore, 132 millions de filles
ne sont pas scolarisés dans le monde
Or, d’après l’ONG Plan International,
chaque année de scolarité en plus
serait le PIB du pays
qui se verrait augmenter.
En France, si l’on permettait
à autant de femmes
de construire des entreprises,
si on permettait à autant de femmes
que d’hommes de construire des entreprises
ce serait 8 milliards d’euros
qui viendraient s’ajouter au PIB annuel.
Les femmes et les filles sont le potentiel
de ce monde pour répondre au chômage,
à la pauvreté et plus largement
aux crises sociales et politiques,
au processus de paix.
L’autonomisation économique des femmes
doit être notre leitmotiv à tous
pour changer notre monde ancien
vers notre monde moderne.
Le plafond de verre n’est pas une fatalité
mais il le deviendra
si on n’y change rien.
Femmes et hommes,
nous ne devons pas nous reposer
sur nos croyances et sur notre passé.
Nous devons oser remettre en question
nos croyances et nos fondations
pour les rebâtir.
Alors, mesdames et petites filles,
soyez ambitieuses et rebelles.
Et messieurs et petits garçons
n’ayez plus peur d’être féministes
pour vouloir l’égalité
pour vos sœurs, pour vos femmes,
pour vos mères, pour vos amies.